mais si on interdit en théorie si on à
terme estimée mais aux ondines messi
messi messi n'est rien ou alors on a
gagné à l'envi du lavoir
on pensait qu'ils font peur aujourd'hui
les bleus oui je pense que des argentins
avaient peur des bleus aujourd'hui c'est
ce qu'on a ressenti une myriade donc je
pensais qu'ils allaient battre les
français mais finalement le français ont
bien pu prouver le contraire
moi je suis fier pas ce n'est que parce
que là les sensations étaient très
fortes
mais bon on verra la suite c'était super
c'est super rien à dire ah ouais je suis
fier du hay
malgré le match mais c'est d'un 0 0
mais la zone c'est à dire gagner les
coeurs aujourd'hui est super on n'avait
pas trop confiance mais nous ont régalés
quand même le match était dur il était
beau à voir
ça fait plaisir de voir les jeunes
français en train de jouer la rapidité
les buts de maps est le plus jeune
d'entre eux c'était un beau match sourit
la suite du mondial a obligé et puis si
on gagne là c'est que la vie là
maintenant aucune équipe ne va arrêter
la france la fonte d'aller en finale
on va rencontrer la coupe du monde